如果我告訴你
你只要在每次下單前
多做一個動作
不用換指標
不用學新招
就可以讓你的勝率到100%到80%
你願不願意花三分鐘聽聽看
這個動作我稱它為
進風轉落
風向對了
你想不贏東南
我是Mokka
全職做當初超過8年
過去5年
幫助超過3000位學生
脫離了不斷虧損的財務困境
我們大部分人
開始學當初是怎麼學的
有些人學的是技術指標
KD黃金交叉的
白MCD翻黑了
空
5分K
獲得錢高
趕緊追
有些人學的跟我一樣
從成交名系和無黨掛單
找出主力盤中的多空訊號
無論我們學的是哪一套
我們都以為學的越多
勝率就越高
我們都做錯了一件事
就是把所有的注意力
放在要交易的那檔股票上
當我們專注的盯著
它的每一根K棒
每一個成交量
它的圍買
圍賣量
它的大單成交
這不就像一個船長
把所有精力都放在
看自己的墮盤和船身
卻完全忘了抬頭
看看天象和風向和好遊了嗎
結果就是你技術再厲害
一個大浪打過忙
你照樣翻船
這就是為什麼
很多人即使有了三五年經驗
用盡了所有技巧
勝率卻永遠卡在
是不是10%到60%這個瓶頸
你不是不努力
你只是努力錯了方向
你有沒有過這種經驗
明明你的股票
技術面全都多頭排列
你滿心歡喜的買進去
結果不到10分鐘
大盤突然開始極速的往下殺
你的普遍也跟著跳水直接把你套牢
你錯在哪
你學到的分析方法全都沒有做錯
你錯在你沒注意整個市場的氛圍已經改變了
我們一定要記住
不要逆勢而為
在股市的大海裡
你再大的船也只是小船
不看風向就注定會失敗
所以那個最關鍵的動作是什麼
就是進場前花10秒鐘抬頭看風向
第一看大盤的風向
就是我們的加準指數
它是最大的風
今天大盤是順風還是逆風
你不要在大盤暴跌的時候
還硬要去做多股票
順著大盤的風向操作
你的勝率基礎
就已經從50%
拉到60%到70%了
第二看
看主權的風向
找你的同類股
這就是勝率衝到80%的關鍵密訣
我舉個例子
我今天想做齊鴻
我會先看他的好兄弟
雙鴻是什麼脾氣
如果雙鴻開高走高
其實很強
那齊鴻基本上
也會是這個種式
我做齊鴻的多單
這個風向是順的
勝率就會非常高
同樣的道理
你做男人就要去參考
星星 景碩的顏色
有人開始動了
兄弟們通常會跟著出動
這個步驟就是
建風長多
建大盤的風
建築拳的風
順著風向開船
你自然能又穩又快
這比你學十個
新的技術指標都有用
我知道你接下來會問
那我怎麼知道誰是領頭羊
也擔心我幫你準備好了
過去八年
我透過不斷試錯和驗證
整理出全台股最核心的
一三九名單
一四大盤風向
三是主要族群
九是最重要的領頭羊
掌握了這份名單
你就能掌握台股八成的風向
足夠你應付市場上大部分的股票了
我不只給你名單
我來把我怎麼看他們的脾氣
怎麼判斷進出場時機
全都系統化
做成了一門線上課程的
到下方資訊欄點連結
免費幫看我們的線上視聽課
感受一下這套箭風轉動的系統
為你帶來的大幅提升
我是摩卡
我們下次見